los incendios forestales no dan tregua
en california y varios de los focos ya
son considerados como los más grandes en
la historia del estado
43 bomberos resultaron heridos mientras
que autoridades locales y funcionarios
advierten que lo peor todavía está por
venir
la cámara de representantes de eeuu
aprobó un paquete de ayuda económica
para el servicio postal del país de cara
a las elecciones presidenciales de
noviembre la medida de ver ahora pasará
al senado de mayoría republicana y
rechazada por donald trump que considera
que el voto electrónico favorece al
fraude
y hoy llega la tan esperada final de la
champions league uno de los torneos de
fútbol más importantes del mundo el
parís saint germain se enfrentará al
bayern munich en un acontecimiento
histórico que se jugará en estadios
vacíos por la pandemia de coronavirus
pero que convoca a fanáticos de todo el
mundo tendremos reporte de lisboa
portugal
muy buenos días bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 saludamos a toda
nuestra audiencia muchas gracias por
acompañarnos
justamente ahorita que comenzamos esta
emisión de noticias en california eeuu
donde los incendios siguen sin dar
tregua y algunos de los pocos ya son
catalogados como los más grandes en la
historia del estado funcionarios locales
advierten que lo peor todavía está por
venir y esto teniendo en cuenta que las
condiciones climáticas favorecen la
propagación de las llamas a una
velocidad mucho mayor y además el pedido
de ayuda a otros estados que realizaron
desde el departamento de bomberos de
california se mantiene en pie
california es un estado en crisis 14.000
bomberos han pasado el fin de semana
tratando de contener más de dos docenas
de grandes incendios pero mientras que
el sábado los equipos tuvieron buen
tiempo los meteorólogos han emitido una
advertencia de bandera roja prediciendo
que el regreso de los fuertes vientos
los relámpagos y la poca lluvia
conducirán a más focos en llamas
es trágico pero nuestros jefes en casa
son agresivos en el entrenamiento que
tenemos en la respuesta al trabajo en
campo y nos preparamos adecuadamente
para ello para que podamos venir aquí a
ayudar a las comunidades donde estamos
llamados a servir
la mayoría de los focos están
localizados en el norte del estado cerca
de san francisco y la capital del estado
sacramento donde las llamas ya han
arrasado más de 400 mil hectáreas 700
hogares han sido devastados varias
personas han muerto y decenas de miles
han sido evacuadas a áreas más seguras
me dijeron que estaríamos fuera una
semana probablemente pero las casas de
las zonas más altas de la montaña
estamos hablando de dos o tres semanas
si es que queda algo para que vuelvas y
un chico reactivo
más práctico tengo varios amigos que
perdieron sus casas y muchos más que
están evacuados así que es un momento
muy difícil pero es genial ver a la
comunidad unida para hacer lo que
podamos para apoyarnos unos a otros los
funcionarios de estado han advertido de
que lo peor aún no ha pasado y se ha
dicho que los residentes de pueblos como
santa cruz que hasta ahora no han sido
tocados por las llamas se preparen para
salir de sus casas en un breve plazo
y para conocer más de cerca la situación
que se vive en california eeuu nos
acompaña a rigoberto herrera el ex
portavoz del departamento forestal y de
protección contra incendios de
california señor herrera muchísimas
gracias por su presencia en france 24
preguntaron en primer lugar si hay
factores que hacen de esta región un
escenario más susceptible o propenso a
este tipo de conflagraciones
sí buenos días si estamos anticipando
ahorita unos vientos que vengan van a
ser eróticos que vienen en diferentes
direcciones estamos anticipando que los
vientos lleguen hasta las 65 millas por
hora que viene siendo muy peligroso
porque puede causar que el incendio
crezca mucho más rápido que lo que
estamos anticipando pero todavía tenemos
refuerzos tratando de llegar a las áreas
o poner refuerzos en frente de esas
áreas donde tengamos probablemente hay
algún problema claro sí si las
condiciones climáticas claramente no
están ayudando ha hablado usted de
refuerzos california pidió ayuda a otros
estados del país y también pidió su
internacional a canadá australia son
insuficientes los recursos del estado
para hacer frente a esta situación sí
pues con eso estamos batallando más o
menos 27 incendios
en todo el estado todos los recursos que
tenemos están batallando los incendios
está causando que cuando pidamos más
refuerzos no puedan ser mandados o si
los recibimos tardan en llegar que causa
que el incendio crezca también con eso
el humo y la el clima los aires no está
documentando no está ayudando para que
las avionetas ni los helicópteros podrán
volar y también los las avionetas y los
helicópteros no pueden volar cuando hay
mucho humo en el aire está causando que
no podamos mandar los recursos a unas
áreas porque es muy peligroso y a veces
ocupamos que esos avionetas o
helicópteros
ayuden a los refuerzos en el piso
rigoberto herrera muchísimas gracias por
su testimonio en france 24 estaremos
bien atento a lo que suceda con las
conflagraciones de california mientras
tanto seguimos en eeuu porque la cámara
de representantes aprobó entregar 25 mil
millones de dólares
al servicio postal y bloqueó los cambios
que generaban preocupación de cara a las
elecciones presidenciales de noviembre y
el voto por correo
los demócratas acusan al presidente de
donald trump de intentar suprimir votos
mientras que el mandatario denuncia sin
pruebas todavía que el voto por correo
es una posible fuente de fraude los
detalles los tiene andrés meza monjos
se acercan las elecciones presidenciales
y esta será la votación por correo más
grande en la historia de eeuu debido a
la pandemia de kobe 19 la cámara de
representantes aprobó una legislación
con la que busca inyectar 25 mil
millones de dólares al servicio postal y
también bloquea una serie de cambios que
pueden dificultar los comicios presten
atención a lo que dice el presidente
porque todo está diseñado para suprimir
el voto saben un plan para votar haganlo
para votar temprano para que tengamos un
resultado que sea claro es lo más cerca
posible de la noche de elección el
proyecto de ley se enmarca en la
polémica que generó el director del
servicio postal cuando decidió hacer
cambios drásticos como retirar buzones
de recolección y recortar horas extras
con el objetivo de reducir costos aunque
luego dijo que esas medidas no entrarían
en vigencia hasta después de las
elecciones el presidente de donald trump
había instado a rechazar la legislación
presentada por los demócratas
argumentando sin pruebas que este tipo
de votación favorece el fraude
todo esto es una broma de los demócratas
para dar 25 mil millones de dólares
innecesarios para fines políticos sin
hablar de la estafa en el voto por
correo que están tratando de llevar a
cabo en violación de todo lo que nuestro
país representa el proyecto también
tendrá que llegar al senado de mayoría
republicana pero el líder de la cámara
alta- dijo que no la aprobarán si pasa
esta sería una intervención sin
precedentes en la oficina de correos
cuyos fondos provienen del negocio de la
correspondencia y otros servicios y no
del dinero de los impuestos y noticias
de américa latina méxico sobrepasó la
barrera de las 60.000 muertes y los 550
mil casos positivos de kobe 19 desde la
declaración de la pandemia y esto tras
eeuu y brasil entonces es el país con
más decesos a nivel global según cifras
de la propia secretaría de salud
mexicana los fallecidos suman un total
de 60 mil 254 en las últimas 24 horas se
sumaron 5 mil 928 nuevos contagios con
esta cifra de fallecidos se alcanza el
escenario anticipado
catalogado como catastrófico en junio
pasado por el subsecretario de
prevención y promoción de salud mexicano
hugo lópez gatell
y aunque durante los tres primeros meses
de la pandemia de coronavirus los países
del triángulo norte de centroamérica
estaban optimistas por la reducción de
los homicidios durante el periodo de
aislamiento ahora la violencia se
recrudeció en honduras y también en
guatemala las autoridades temen que la
relativa calma llegó a su fin maría
clara calle tiene todos los detalles
honduras ve como la violencia que se
había reducido durante el aislamiento
está volviendo a surgir la policía dice
que el encierro ayudó a que los
homicidios se redujeran un 15% entre
enero y abril en comparación con el
mismo periodo de 2010 y 9 pero el
observatorio de la violencia de la
universidad nacional asegura que entre
julio y agosto hubo 16 homicidios
múltiples muchos más de los 6 que hubo
antes del aislamiento decretado en marzo
uno de los hechos violentos que más
impacto tuvo en honduras fue la
desaparición de cuatro líderes del grupo
étnico garífuna cualquier cosa que haya
sucedido dentro de la comunidad
cualquier cosa que haya entrado dentro
de la comunidad fue porque el estado no
cumplió no hizo su trabajo para proteger
triunfo de la cruz otro de los países
del triángulo norte de centroamérica
donde se recrudece la violencia es
guatemala justo después del 26 de julio
cuando se eliminó el 'toque de queda' la
policía registró varios ataques de
pandilleros que habían dejado de operar
en la pandemia
expertos aseguran que todo es una
disputa del territorio para controlar la
droga ya su paso desde luego deja
bastante violencia por las rutas por las
disputas incluso también en el
territorio
estos grupos que se dedican a estas
actividades ilícitas del narcotráfico
de los tres países el salvador es el
único donde los homicidios han
disminuido a un tercio de los que se
registraron en 2019 aunque la onu
advirtió que las pandillas más grandes
mara salvatrucha y el barrio 18 se están
camuflando en la economía informal para
extorsionar y negociar pequeñas
cantidades de droga
y en otras noticias lisboa es por estos
días el centro de la actualidad
futbolística la capital la portuguesa
acogió este mes de agosto a los 8
mejores clubes europeos en un evento de
talla mundial que hoy domingo tendrá su
tan esperada final justo cuando tanto la
capital como el país necesitaban que se
reactiven el turismo tras el
confinamiento por la pandemia de
coronavirus natalia ruiz tiene todos los
detalles
la orejona engalana la plaza de rocío y
lisboa es hoy el centro de atención de
los amantes del fútbol aquí se disputa
la fase final de la liga de campeones
por el coronavirus los partidos se
disputan a puerta cerrada los pocos
hinchas de los encuentros por televisión
en bares y restaurantes un sector que
pudo reactivarse por la incorporación
con los tres meses en los que no había
deportes y para un bar como el nuestro
ha sido difícil y ha sido un regalo del
juego sin embargo no todos los lisboetas
comparten ese entusiasmo a pesar de ser
un país de fútbol más saben lo que está
en juego el turismo representa el 18 por
ciento del producto interno bruto
portugués no se siente un cambio esta
competición en portugal es como si no
existiera
lo bueno es que hay menos gente y se
camina mejor en la ciudad lo malo es la
parte económica los turistas hacen falta
es un país que vive esencialmente del
turismo
por causa del virus la mitad de los
hoteles de la ciudad aún no tenían
clientes hace dos meses la liga de
campeones es entonces la vitrina ideal
para lisboa es un instrumento
fundamental para reestablecer la
confianza en este destino
sobre todo y sobre todo para restablecer
una imagen positiva de lisboa y de
portugal en general
la capital espera en los próximos meses
el regreso contundente de los turistas
extranjeros a menos de que una segunda
ola de kobe 19 dañe los planes
y tal como adelantábamos en el informe
previo hoy llega la tan esperada final
de la champions league francia y
alemania- se disputarán la copa en un
encuentro entre el parís saint germain y
el bayern múnich en uno de los torneos
de fútbol más importantes de todo el
mundo que convoca a fanáticos de todas
las nacionalidades la final tendrá lugar
en lisboa la capital portuguesa y
precisamente allí se encuentra natalia
ruiz enviada especial de france en 24 o
la natalia bueno comencemos hablando de
la previa cómo se está viviendo
bueno pues ya ustedes saben el día de
ayer los equipos se entrenaron en el
estadio el estadio de la luz aquí en
lisboa que es también la casa del
benfica el club local hoy han tenido un
día mucho más tranquilo tendrán una
siesta y antes de salir al estadio habrá
esa charla técnica que será muy
importante antes de la final de esta
noche y bueno por el lado de la parís a
sandra man pues tomás to hell' dice que
solamente esta tarde sabrá si keylor
navas el arquero costarricense será
titular o no ustedes tal vez lo
recuerdan él se lesionó en el partido de
cuartos de final entre el atalanta y
desde entonces no ha jugado y por parte
del bayern múnich la única incógnita por
ahora es saber si jerome boateng quien
es el pilar uno de los pilares de la
zaga bávara estará listo no porque él
salió en el partido de semifinal ante el
antequera del lunes con un problemita
muscular pero no pareciera al menos eso
es lo que dio a entender ansía fli que
el director técnico de la valla múnich
de que no sea algo muy grave por ahora
así que así están las cosas que hay
bueno acá en esta plaza que ya la
animación comienza también
llegar con los hinchas de ambos equipos
natalia se dice que es un evento un
acontecimiento histórico esta final
contanos brevemente por qué
así es por una parte porque esta final
es atípica esta final debía jugarse en
istanbul a finales de mayo pero con el
parón por esta pandemia de coronavirus
todos los partidos se pararon es en el
mes de marzo y luego pues la uefa
decidió terminar lo que quedaba de copa
en una semana partidos a eliminación
directa con los ocho mejores equipos que
todavía estaban en liza aquí en lisboa y
por otra parte soy porque bueno si hoy
el par y se llama gana será la primera
vez que gane y bueno el bayern munich
espera su sexta corona gracias la tarea
por este reporte a nuestra audiencia le
invitamos a continuar informando se en
el resto de nuestra programación y en
france24 punto com
[Música]